>>> All right.
Last week an artificial
intelligence company opened ai
unveiled chatgpt4.
The ai language tool that's
frightening people around the
wool, gpt4 that can analyze
thousands of words and text that
can analyze everything, coding,
to passing standardized tests
and it can even write lawsuits.
Ai technology is developing at a
dizzying pace and able to
re-create voices as Antonio
Sullivan found out and we showed
it to you last weekend by using
one to simulate his own voice in
a phone call with his parents.
>> How are you doing?
>> Hi, dad.
How are you?
>> Good.
Yourself?
>> Just finished shooting our
story here.
I'm going to the airport in a
while.
>> Oh, you're going back?
>> The plane this weekend.
>> Okay.
Well, it may seem like fun and
games.
Ai technology can even be used
to create so-called deep fakes.
That's not so funny which are
digital masks that can replicate
the look of just about anyone
like this.
>> If you're a pretty good
climber I want to see you climb
this.
Not easy to do.
Discipline and hard work.
I don't know what I'm talking
about.
It's crazy!
>> Remember that?
That was not Tom Cruise even
though it looked like him.
Some are now raising alarms
about how these advances could
be used to create and spread
misinformation.
Our next guest is an ai expert
and amerity us professor of
psychology and author of
rebooting ai, building
artificial intelligence we can
trust.
Welcome, Dr. Gary Marcus.
Good to see you.
>> Thanks for having me.
Doctor, you know more about this
technology than most.
You've even developed your own
versions.
So for all of us who are just
learning about this whole world
of ai, how does it work in its
current form and why is it that
you are concerned about kind of
the next level?
What can happen next?
>> I think the first thing to
understand is it's not as
intelligence as it looks.
It's mimicking a huge database
of things that it's seen before
and it is so huge that an
ordinary human being probably
can't imagine how huge it is and
it's billions of texts and what
it's doing is it's prestiging
them, it's piecing together
weird things.
It blamed the silicon valley
bank on gpt5 and it didn't
exist.
Even though it looks smart it's
making stuff up.
>> Maybe it shouldn't be called
artificial intelligence, but
something else.
You wrote an article in "The
atlantic."
We talked about how bad actors
can manipulate the powers of the
ai tools to spread
misinformation.
I guess, what are the degrees of
your worries about this?
Is there going to be a point
where it's going to be difficult
to differentiate real thing from
ai generated if we're not there
already?
>> We are very close to that
point right now, and part of the
concern that bad actors can
deliberately use this to miss
inform people.
It's one thing to have fun with
Tom Cruise and having him say
something wacky, but you can
imagine troll farms trying to
influence our elections and my
single biggest fear is that that
people will disrupt democracy by
making an atmosphere where we
can't trust anything.
Where when you look at Twitter
and you look at Facebook, you
don't know what's true anymore.
>> Right.
>> The sheer volume that you can
make with these machines.
You can make millions and
billions of misinformation a day
with your own alternative set of
facts are and it's plausible and
it rz references and data and
most humans won't be able to
tell the difference and a lot of
people can't trust anything.
>> That's my biggest worry.
We just came off of it.
A lot of people are stuck.
They've used the terminology of
fake news and then people
believe it and then you have
this forum, these tools that can
help that happen and look more
believable and people can't
discern the difference between
real and fake.
I feel like we may have run into
this jurassic park moment where
these ai creators are so
preoccupied with whether they
could, they didn't stop to think
if we really should.
>> I think that's exactly right.
I wrote another essay, the
jurassic park moment of ai and
quoted that bit.
I quoted Jeff blume and how that
accurate is.
In terms of the uses of
misinformation and in terms of
accidental misinformation around
health and ultimately people